hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to VHS a video horror story
which is an indie horror game that I
found on its you and if you're also
wondering yes I'm wearing makeup but you
don't need to wonder why I was doing it
for the shoot that we did today but I
won't go into too many details because
it's not important right now look for
the video next week you'll know when you
see it but this game right here
supposedly scary it's also on the year
of my birth 1989 changed frequency to
reveal objects oh what the [ __ ]
what Oh what the hell what the fall hi
hi okay I'm not sure I'm understanding
this yes okay oh oh there literally
there oh but I can only see them
[Music]
[ __ ] it duck something over there I have
no idea okay
I don't know what I'm doing or what's
going on why I'm here holy Sh oh hi a
[ __ ] you okay
hide objects and reveal other things
alrighty then okay you something's in
there something bad was it looking at me
oh is that Elvis I don't know which is
better okay I'm gonna move on now
right then ah no objects standing in my
way
alrighty then moving along okay
Hey I don't like this fact that you can
only see one thing at a time that's
awfully bad okay I need to see you have
to run to be able to navigate it boy so
how am I gonna be able to know when
something is about to eat my face off
leash law hey hey okay so I don't know
the story behind this but I like the
concept I mean I don't enjoy the concept
but I like it
[Music]
looking at here we're looking at we're
looking at something I don't know what
I'm told to be able to do about this
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh boy
is that a good thing or a bad thing huh
no idea which I'm a brave boy gonna
press forward no matter what I hear oh
that's I what the [ __ ] okay I saw that
okay I saw that that's okay
see what's over here oh that's bad
but something big something big is over
there who's stomping
[Music]
okay hi
all right then but that's okay you stop
stepping if I go this way
oh there's nothing in my way it's my way
what's in my way
oh five [ __ ] chairs hate this
don't come over here okay I'm sorry it
was just a warning I didn't want to have
to punch you in the face whatever you
have that you call fades okay it's not
gonna come after me oh oh is that the
thing it's not gonna come after me
oh [ __ ] ice oh my god
holy [ __ ] look at you oh so it's Tim
stomping I just got to get around the
goddamn days you jokester [ __ ] alright
but there's plenty of time as it goes
around the table but it doesn't seem to
be able to see me I just have a tie ish
this office went to [ __ ] I think I need
to talk to HR about this one
okay we did it all right good we made it
alive somehow I don't like that okay
I'm in here now what good does that do
me any monsters dead body parts as
always good and comforting very
reassuring I don't know where I'm
supposed to be going with this [ __ ] I
give this walls by oh [ __ ] hi okay so
your stem stopping over there you're all
over here seems to be a clear path you
come back pretty good don't come here
okay all right such a bizarre concept to
be able to change frequencies in to see
things as they arrive what the [ __ ] did
the frequency change oh boy oh boy oh
boy I don't know why stop it why did I
come here it's a goddamn dead-end a [ __ ]
I wasn't changing the frequencies it was
changing it on me Wow
okay all right okay okay I get it I get
it yeah
stop stop okay somewhere over here but
[ __ ] okay all right yeah you turn
around okay it's just ajust UNAM me I
gotta just back oh [ __ ] no you hey buddy
hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy
hey okay [ __ ] off
oh boy and I'm gonna need to put a
seizure warning at the beginning of this
one because it is [ __ ] jarring his
[ __ ] looking ducking
this way I guess this Way's good as any
[Music]
how's the goddamn dead end again I said
help anybody does I'll be hey hey friend
oh I know
[Music]
okay all right that's cool of you
yeah I can go right now okay yes I can
it's gonna go down that way so I can go
down this way good to see where I'm
going
yo yo yo yo I hope this isn't the way I
came this yes oh boy oh boy there's some
in here where is it
oh it is
yeah yeah I I saw it in here okay okay
see nothing okay I almost saw you there
yeah we're at big boy okay you're up
there maybe okay is okay
seems clear all right okay it's it's
relatively okay think
focus focus there we go okay which way
you going buddy
you come this way or you going that way
go that way are too good to say that way
like as I [ __ ] okay snip snip stick
stick stick yeah anything else
hey I'll see you [ __ ] [ __ ] where am i
speaking by here yes got it in 20 get
exit yes yes yes okay fine wah [ __ ] off
[Music]
oh no no no no
god damn it you [ __ ] ow my lymph node
oh [ __ ] off with your fake blue screen
of death ah
that was really cool that was
legitimately awesome because I've never
seen a mechanic like that I mean there's
been mechanics like that where you have
night vision and it's something where
you trade off one or the other and
you're supposed to do like you can only
see things during night vision but
having something like that where it's a
mechanic where you have to tune in and
tune out of it it makes so much sense
and also it makes it incredibly scary
because you have no idea where they are
I liked a lot the enemies were kind of
interesting they were patrolling more
than they were coming after you and then
the ending I get it it's pretty good but
either way that was pretty cool so did
the developers of this one thank you so
much for making this this is cool this
is very unique I like it a lot this
could make for a really cool hoards so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to try for yourself I put a
link in the description and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]